if you want to do great things you need
to be surrounded by greatness you need
to create a great environment so whether
you're driving to the office working at
your desk or relaxed at home put this on
in the background as a soundtrack to
help you inspire the greatness inside
you that third failure in a row did you
think I need to pack this in yeah why
not
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or living fast I'm not gonna sit inside
of a corporation for 20 years the time
is now the time is now to express and
for people to believe in themselves the
time is now for it to be okay
to be great people in this world shun
people for being great for being a
bright color for standing out but the
time is now to be okay to be the
greatest you what I decided to do this I
I first talked to my my wife who is
sitting here in the audience and she had
married a you know relatively stable
goofy but still relatively stable a
person working at a Wall Street firm we
were to the quantitative hedge fund and
this was a hard decision and I was
looking for the right framework in which
to make that kind of important decision
and and and and the right framework I
found is a regret minimization framework
and that's just a nerdy way of saying
that you want to project yourself to age
80 and then think back over your life
and if you're if you're if you're 80
what are the that you want to minimize
the number of regrets you have
throughout that period of time I think
this is something a lot of people do
maybe subconsciously they probably very
few people probably name it regret
minimization framework because most
people are healthier than that but but
it was a very clear way for me to think
about making that kind of life decision
and then
in the way it helped was I thought okay
if I go do this thing and participate in
this thing called the internet that I
genuinely believe is gonna be a big deal
and if I fail am I gonna regret having
tried and failed and I knew the answer
that was no but I also knew that if I
didn't try that I would always regret
that I would always wonder and it would
haunt me and until that you know
mythical day which I actually hope will
come 9:00 to 5:00 aren't good because
you look you husband fourth weekend but
when you can do something that's for
yourself and your family
it never feels like work I hustle for my
hustle for my last name I don't hustle
for my first when I graduate from
universities and before you know for
three years I tried fill in two
universities so I applied jobs for
thirty times got rejected
I went for a police they said no you're
not good I went to you know even the KFC
when KFC came to check up do I say see
24 people went for the job 23 people
accepted I was the only one guy and we
went for please five people all of them
accepted I was the only guy did I
receive receive it so to me pain turned
down rejected oh by the way I told you
that I would apply for Harvard for ten
times rejected ten times you wrote them
and said I'd like to come to Harvard
yeah
and then I told myself somebody I should
go teach there baby
really liking what you do what whatever
area that you get into given that you
know even if you if you're the best the
best there's always a chance of failure
so I think it's important that you
really like whatever you're doing if you
don't like it life is too short if you
like what you're doing you think about
it even when you're not working I mean
it'll just it's it's something that your
mind is drawn to and and if you don't
like it you just really can't make it
work I think when this goes online or
whatever it is
it really matters and it like really
doesn't matter what matters is you know
the people who are sparked by it and the
people who are like offended by it it
doesn't matter you you know like because
it's about motivating the doers and
anyone that wants to sit around and talk
they're doing too much time they've
taken too much time talking good about
it instead of getting up off their ass
and following their dreams because I'm
here to follow my dreams you know and
help other people follow their dreams
and inspire people who are dreamers it's
crazy that we live in a world that if
you're super positive and super creative
then it's scary so what does that tell
you about the mentality of most people
if you're scared of like positivity and
creativity many many kids and many
grown-ups do figure out over time what
their passions are and sometimes we let
our I don't think it's that hard I think
what happens though sometimes is that we
let our intellectual selves overrule
those passions and so that's what needs
to be guarded against I've learned over
the years that you know with anything
you have to be patient not in five years
patient or five you know five months
patient you know you could be 10 years
patient if you want to you know empires
aren't built overnight you know they
mean like I always tell you by the great
wall was a 2000 year old plan
2000 your many lifetimes that isn't one
plan you know and getting people to to
to kind of you know do the same have the
same exact agenda for lifetimes the
generations that's crazy so you know you
have to be patient when you want to do
something significant no matter what and
a lot of time that means you know not
reaping the benefits of something
immediately
you know and that's the test just like
Open Sesame
be the secret code for Alibaba the
secret coming for everybody's keep your
dream alive because it might come true
someday this is what the secret cookies
so many people try to talk me out of
starting her own company it was it was
crazy one good friend of mine collected
a whole series of videos of rockets
blowing up and made me watch those you
just didn't want me to lose all my money
we're doing these things that seem
unlikely to succeed and we've been
fortunate and at least thus far they
have succeeded
beyond
I'm gonna put the vast majority of my
energy attention and dollars into
building a great product or service and
put a smaller amount into shouting about
it marketing it because I know if I
build a great product or service my
customers will tell each other you have
to mix in some patience with that I
don't think my approach on business is
with the average person would advise
like most I hear people say never put up
your own money and I'm saying put your
own money up work harder than everyone
be patient and just know that if you're
gonna do something on your own you're
gonna have to feel something what do you
think your core competence is I'll call
this culture it's not the technology I
think technology is a to the core
components of our companies we have 220
Fowler grow from 18 people to now 20,000
young people and we focus a lot on the
value in a mission and making sure the
culture everybody work for helping
others instead how instead of you know
just to make you money now is the time
to take risk you don't have kids as you
get older your obligations increase so
you're and once you have a family you
start taking risks not just for yourself
but for your family as well it gets much
harder to do things that might not work
out so now is the time to do that before
you before you have those obligations so
I would encourage you to take risks now
do something bold you won't regret it
everyone out there in TV world real
world whatever world you stay in needs
to know that I've never done a publicity
stunt of my life anytime I went up and
spoke my mind whether they put my career
in jeopardy or whatever it's someone
so-called said it was always what I
thought was the truth whether I'm like
reading through a teleprompter or
whatever or whatever I felt emotionally
I don't follow like rules of like you
know normal celebrity or what their
publicist tells them to say or anything
but I say things the wrong way a lot of
times if my intention is always positive
and I want to bring more things to the
world I want to help the world I want to
make people's lives easier I said if you
guys look at the same interview it's
really something extremely fearless for
someone in my position to do because
most people just like you know bow tie
on a TV or whatever bow down to these
cameras like I could care less about any
of these cameras in all honesty all
care about is my family I care about
protecting my girl protecting my baby
and protecting my ideas and my dreams
yes I'm totally weird and I'm totally
honest and I'm totally inappropriate
sometimes and the thing is I you know
for me to say I wasn't a genius I would
just be lying to you and to myself
almost seven years ago now I started
this most incredible journey called
amazon.com actually at that time it
wasn't even called amazon.com it was
called Cadabra Inc as an abracadabra
that was the original name of the
company and I had phoned a lawyer on the
way to Seattle from a cell phone and he
said well what do you to incorporate the
company he said what do you want the
company to be called and I said Cadabra
he said cadaver and I knew that was a
bad name we changed it a few months
later you know you always have to have
something that's paying your bills so
that whatever you're creating can
breathe so you don't have to rush it you
don't have to make it push it to make
money when it's not ready you know I
mean like you kind of always have to
have something solid and then you that's
paying your bills you know cause even as
an artist to me as a man you still have
the responsibility to take care of your
woman to take care of your children and
to take care of yourself and you know
almost in that order it's like children
your woman and then yourself you know
what I'm saying but all of that should
be able to be taken care if that's a
real man you know and as an artist you
can't say alright well I'm not going to
take care of my children or take care of
my woman or even take care of myself
well to protect my artistry then that's
not artistry to me that's just being
lazy you know I'm saying I think as an
artist you have to fight for that
artistry you know what I'm saying like
you have to figure out how to pay your
bills so that the artistry can breathe
you know what I mean and it also you
know you get taught you feel like I'm a
real man people don't like it so many
people I talked to at that time for all
you pay they say this is the stupidest
idea you have ever got but I think I
don't wear the stupid a club as long as
people use it now we have 800 million
people using this Alipay how did you
figure you were going to start a car
company and be six
well I didn't really think Tesla would
be successful I thought we would most
likely fail but I thought that we at
least could address the false perception
that people had that an electric car had
to be ugly and slow and and boring like
a golf cart but you say you didn't
expect the company to be successful then
why try if something is important enough
you should try even if you probably
outcome is failure
okay so used to be John Stephens yes
Kanye West who said change to legend you
know the first person actually was a guy
named Jay IV who's also from Chicago and
is a friend of mine and Kanye's and he's
a poet
and we working on Kanye's album and
Kanye was having me seeing all these
parts and jiv was just like man we're
gonna have to call you the legend cuz
you know my voice is kind of old-school
I've always had an old soul Connie as I
maybe should just call yourself John
Legend and I was like no that's
ridiculous big bold things and you know
maybe I'll just roll with this whole
John Legend thing and my kind of
ultimate deciding factor was let's not
not do it out of fear because because
you're afraid to call yourself oh yeah
let's not not doing because because I'm
afraid that it won't work out because
people could laugh at you if you don't
have a good career and you're going
around calling yourself legend you think
you now live up to it I think I'm
working on it I'm on my way but we have
always wanted to do is raise the
standard for what it means to be
customer centric to such a degree that
other organizations whether they be
other companies or whether they be
hospitals or government agencies
whatever the organization is they should
look at Amazon as a role model and say
how can we be as customer centric as
Amazon even competitors I imagine right
hopefully competitors as well but if we
could make you know if that could be our
legacy that we kind of raised the
general idea of what it means to be
customer centric that would be a huge
accomplishment it would be accomplishing
a mission that's much bigger than
ourselves have you ever watched a James
Bond movie for
he's losing at some point and then he
wins or Batman or Iron Man or any
superhero there has to be some diversity
for you to you know overcome to win no
it can't be a champ unless you uh you
know are in a place where you look like
you're gonna lose and then you win the
pain that's gonna come with being
independent you have to embrace it
because it's gonna happen and also know
that the more successful you get the
more problems you're gonna have the more
not you're gonna have downtime being a
boss does not mean smooth sailing it
means having the ability to care about
other people before yourself and to
untie problems untie knots
that's all it is there's it's not
business if there's not problem there's
nothing good without struggle it just
doesn't happen and all my experiences
there hasn't been one thing that's been
successful without me feeling some pain
before it was successful so now when
there is pain I embrace it you know I've
been embracing it I'm aji about it
because I know that must mean that if
I'm cool man you know what awaits me
it's the darkest before the dawn I don't
I don't want to like sound corny but
that's really what that's what has to
happen I learned a lot of things from
from movies I learned how to make a
speech from the movie code bodyguard
Whitney Houston when she sings the Suns
I look at her wow that's the way that
you make a speaker because I never know
how to make speech because I'm not actor
but when I saw the movie I said wow if
you sing from your heart
if you seem naturally if you are
yourself so I I realize and I learn a
lot from the movies you know even learn
from the Godfather's I learn my favorite
movies the forest the gum you know these
these are the things I learned so much
then I will discuss about the the muse
the inspiration so we got from movies
they focus on on signal over noise a lot
of companies get gift confused that they
spend money on things that don't
actually make the product better for
example at Tesla we've never spent any
money on advertising we put all the
money into R&D and manufacturing and
design to try to make the car as good as
possible
and I think that's that's the way to go
if we're for any given company just keep
thinking about
are these efforts that people are
expending are they resulting in a better
product or service if they're not stop
those efforts right here bring a mr.
West my name is cam gray from the 937
came to annihilate my cane young
heavyweight primate young came braced in
in front of Kanye I wish you would give
me a deal that's what I needed
that's where my whole life is I've been
dreaming that's what I got I feel it
that's what I got I made this happen
last night I told my homie this what
happened I told him I meet again at
Kanye then we took it do a ring
I was born in Tennessee with my heart
stays up in Ohio keep my weight on your
feet Callie being on that for a while
mother see I'm the best in the Midwest
better mention me yeah my name is cam
gray $120 T I couldn't afford from a PC
I'm not done man I got my degree I got
my life together I got my together come
on real give me a chance for me I swear
to god man swear to God to be open to
start off as like an assistant man I'm
down and start anything I just want to
learn somewhere Batman Oliver thank you
very much thank you for your time
Cameron great camera great we know
customers like low prices we know
customers like big selection and we know
that customers like fast delivery and
those things are going to be true 10
years from now they're gonna be true 20
years from now so we can count on those
things and we can put energy into them
we know customers like their products
fast and so we work on things that we
know customers like what has worked at
Amazon is focusing on the customer being
very cutting the customer first which is
easy to say but difficult to do if you
really are customer centric it's like
being the host of a party you're holding
the party for your guests
sometimes the host the party is holding
the party for the host of the party and
that's that leads to a different kind of
party I'm always gonna play fair you
know what I mean like I don't believe in
doing anything unless it's fair because
I believe there's always karmic
repercussions from doing things unfair
so what can appear to be a win or
something that appears to be a fast you
know fast money and in I know in the
long run I'm gonna suffer but you know
it's always a test quick anything quick
as a test you know I can get it quick if
I don't have to cheat but if it you know
if I've got a cheat to get Affairs I
don't want it what kinds of business
ideas have you said no to I'm saying no
to a lot of ideas because as a CEO I
have to say no to opportunities because
if I say yes I probably get a 5,000
opportunities every day but where the
years are no everything based on the
meshing that
helpings doing business easier if it's
on that we'll consider if our somebody
come here saying can you we will you
don't have does it you will make a lot
of money I'm not interested
when interview someone to work the
companies to be to ask me tell me about
the problems that they worked on and how
they sold them and if someone was really
the person that solved it they'll be
able to answer multiple levels they'll
be able to go down to the brass tacks
and if they weren't they'll get stuck
and then you can say oh this person was
not really the person who solved it
because anyone who struggled hard with a
problem against it so many people are
just so obvious they don't even realize
that when they box me in or try to
verbally put me in some type of box will
put Dada in a box that they're really
showing their level of ignorance they're
putting themselves in a box and you know
people can write write write all they
want but what are people doing and if
there's anybody that's out there doing
they know how hard it is to actually do
and I'm like a motivation of the doers
if if everything I did failed which it
doesn't it actually succeeds but if
everything I did failed just the fact
that I'm willing to fail is an
inspiration people are so scared to lose
that they don't even try like one thing
that people can't say is they can't say
I'm not trying and I'm not trying my
hardest and I'm not trying to do it the
best way that I know how with what
little information I get my advice would
be the same for any kind of entrepreneur
and that is make sure that you are
focused on something you're passionate
about so if you look at the early
internet companies they were started and
focused on doing something that they
thought was very interesting long before
the internet was fashionable in anyway
you know I I you know we are currently
an underdog once again we've been in
business for six years and there was
exactly one year where we were not the
underdog and that was 1999 I like the
the underdog years because it makes you
know I liked it when all the people we
hired their parents told them they were
crazy like that was the
kind of the good era fortunately it's
back in 1999 all the parents were like
you know given their brothers and
sisters high-fives you know my son is
working at amazon.com so that's a very
you can't follow the fashion when you're
trying to do a startup company or I
think really anything in life but you
have to as an entrepreneur if you're
gonna if you're gonna build a company
pick something you think is interesting
that has the intersection of genuinely
creating real customer value and then
just stay right there and let the wave
catch you my parents haven't bought me
clothes since I was about 14 my parents
haven't I haven't had nobody buy me
nothing let's say that no one's taking
care of me since I was 14 years old and
I didn't want nobody taking care because
they couldn't what they was trying to
buy me I wasn't trying to wear why did
you call it Ali Baba
Ali Baba well when I started I think
Internet is Guillou but we should have a
global name and I named that interesting
like at that time the best name is Yahoo
right I think I can so I've been
thinking for many days suddenly think
Alibaba is a good name so I I was
happened to being sent San Francisco
that day never didn't have a launch and
the waitress can I ask you do you know
that Alibaba
should you say yes I see what is Alibaba
she said Open Sesame
good so I went on the street ask about
10 20 people they all know about Alibaba
40 thieves and Open Sesame
and I think this is a good name and
study with a whatever you talk about all
the bubbles on the top
if you're creating company or if you're
joining a company the most important
thing is to make sure is to attract
great people so either view would join a
group that's amazing that you've really
respect or if you've building a company
you've got to gather great people I mean
all the company is is a group of people
that have gathered together to create a
product or service and so depending upon
how talented and hardworking that group
is and degree to which they are focused
cohesively in a good direction that will
determine the success of the company
so do everything you can to to gather
great people if you're creating a
company I refuse to follow those rules
the society is set up and the way that
they control people with low self-esteem
with improper information with branding
with marketing I refuse to follow those
rules it's about truth it's about
information
it's about awesomeness and the only
luxury is time the time you spend with
your family that's the only luxury so
this concept of luxury is improper to me
when I compare myself to Steve Jobs or
Walt Disney Howard Hughes David Stern
Michelangelo da Vinci Jesus or whatever
as I'm saying these are my heroes these
are people that I look up to this is the
type of impact I want to make on the
earth if I can make this type of impact
up to this point what can I do if if you
call Bob Iger and say yo give him a shot
if you call Oprah and say yo back this
kid let's just get this kid this kids a
kids were his parents were educators he
wants to educate he wants to look at
curriculums and say how do we simplify
that exactly what I did in music I want
to apply to product I want to apply to
education this is what my company Donda
is about this is you can hold a ballet
and that can be successful and you can
hold a rock concert and that can be
successful just don't hold a ballet and
advertise it as a rock concert and so
you need to be clear with all of your
stakeholders with you know are you
holding a ballet or you holding a rock
concert and then people get to
self-select in you know we hire people
who are who are really motivated by
building new customer experiences they
like to pioneer
they like the rate of change they they
wake up in the shower motivated by
thinking about customers and
occasionally somebody joins Amazon who
their primary motivation comes from
being thinking about competition or
competitors those people can find Amazon
a little Dolph you know so and again
it's not about right or wrong it's just
that different people are motivated by
different things and what happens with
corporate cultures is that over time
that you people collect themselves you
know in a way where they like that
culture and then it becomes
self-sustaining taste talent and work
ethic you know what I mean and all of it
I need all of it you know taste talent
workout fish you know perspective so
when I interview or might even when my
the people I work with find more talent
they have to bring me I have to get a
mixtape from them can't even know what
music they're listening to because taste
of music tells a lot about a person it
really does I got to know who the best
their favorite designer is what's the
last book they read favorite artist and
it's funny but sometimes you know you
get those yeah the answers are hilarious
but people be trying they don't have you
know but you know you honestly have to
have you're like I look for all your
senses to be activated you know I mean
like I need you have good taste in music
I need your work ethic I need you to be
a good person I need you should have a
good taste in clothes you know I need to
be at you need to be able to be savvy
and more than just one thing like
everyone in my staff can do like there's
not one job that anyone does in my staff
we believe to cook on be different from
the Wall Street we believe custom number
one employee number two share a number
for customer one employee to share
number three yeah are we again this is
my religion you know if you it's the
custom that pays the money it's the
employees that drive the innovation it's
the shareholder in a shareholder always
say you know I remember the day before
we IPO and a lot of people say can I
keep about the shares we were long-term
shareholders but when the crisis came
these guys wrong as soon as you know
ran away my people stayed custom stay
you got to make sure that whatever
you're doing is a great product or
service it has to be really great and I
go back to what I was saying earlier
where if you're a new company I mean
this is like some new industry or new
market that if it's an untapped market
or then then you have more ability to
give is this the standard is lower for
your product or service but if you're
entering anything where there's an
existing market place against lodge and
trenched competitors then your product
or service needs to be much better than
theirs it can't be a little bit better
because then you put yourself in the
shoes of the consumer and they say why
would you buy it as a consumer you're
always going to buy the trusted brand
unless there's a big difference so a lot
of times you know entrepreneur will come
up with something which is only slightly
better and it's it's not you can't just
be slightly better it's got to be a lot
better there's a series of you know
people who like right just negative
comments they want to joke around and
say why is he still trying
you know if I see something I see
opportunity I'm gonna go for it I'm here
to crack the pavement and make new
grounds
you know sonically and in society
culturally we're not always in the
position that we want to be at we're
constantly growing we're constantly
making mistakes because he's trying to
express ourselves they're trying to
actualize our dreams I want to create
something better for you we have been
limited it's bigger than you know who I
am
even in this you know in my presence
living it's about you know when I was on
earth what did I do to help I want
people to think more I want people to
feel like it's okay to create and follow
what their dreams are and not feel boxed
in I want people to feel like awesome is
possible there's a lack of creativity in
every field because people are afraid as
an artist and in this world we could do
whatever we want one of the things
you've done so well at Amazon is you've
undercut all of your rivals by keeping
the prices low does that same strategy
apply to tablets yes our approach is
premium products and non premium prices
so we saw the hardware at break-even so
we don't try to make any money when we
saw this hardware and we hope to make
money when people use the devices not
when they buy the devices and so that's
a very different approach from most
companies most companies are building
quite a bit of profit into the sale of
these devices if I make a regular
business that doesn't touch pop culture
it doesn't make history then to some
people that could be considered going
backwards that's not a pressure for me
because I could care less what people
think and I don't think there's anything
about my career where you would think I
did it for someone else I'm just
constantly trying to impress myself like
I've accomplished you know relatively
speaking a lot of things and because of
that I've been able to do exactly what
inspires where is the opportunities
people start complaining
some people complain
that people started change themselves
check the others where the opportunities
is where they can place our weather
trouble where's the key if anyone helped
well you want to do a particularly tree
starting a company you need to work
super hot so what is super heart mean
well when my brother and I were starting
our first company instead of getting an
apartment we just rented us a small
office and we slept on the couch and we
showered at the YMCA and we're so hot up
we had one computer so the the website
was up during the day and I was coding
at night seven days a week all the time
and I sort of briefly had a girlfriend
in that period and in order to deal with
me she have to sleep in the office so I
work hard like it mean every waking hour
that's that's the the thing I would I
would say if your particular if you're
starting a company and I mean if you do
simple math to say like okay if somebody
else is working 50 hours and you're
working a hundred you'll get twice as
done as much done in the course of a
year as the other company you know so
you're gonna love me you're gonna hate
me but imma be me whatever it is that
you want to do your there's gonna be
risk in your life and risk is a
necessary component of progress you can
make any pioneering movements in the
world of any kind whether they be the
geographical physical exploration that
I've just been talking about or whether
it be you know a more cerebral
exploration of a scientific field or I
bet you could ask that question of every
speaker here and I bet that every
speaker here has taken substantial risks
whether it be intellectual or otherwise
to achieve what they're you know what
they've done everyone has the ability to
take care of themselves you can always
be a hunter you could always eat the
food you kill it's just about how lazy
you are you know there's a theory it's
all about your effort
then jumping will jump to each other the
Lincoln Championships a funny thought
that's where she won Fanta so good not
that triple you get what you want you
think I don't know bogan surrounded him
harder panting well Vincent over the
political dimension values on the cheeks
it's how we you don't venerability no
but you guys are living in onion
thank you for joining me for this
episode of environment I love to know
what you think if you want to leave a
comment below I hope you continue to
believe and surround yourself with
greatness